president erdogan you're live on Sky
News we're broadcasting around the world
would you what would you like to say to
the people who are supporting your
country
a president under pressure putting on a
brave face meeting survivors following
criticism his government has been too
slow to act
I wanted to ask him about the support
that has been received
from around the world right at this
moment and what more sorry and what more
might be needed for the people of South
Eastern Turkey all the infrastructure
has gone here
here in adiaman the situation is
desperate seventy percent of buildings
damage 30 percent completely wiped out
for nearly two days they waited for the
aid to arrive president erdogan conceded
help to the worst affected areas were
slow for the first day but now the
rescue and Recovery operation is in full
swing
I'm so sorry that we cannot rescue
everyone as quickly as possible
all the municipalities and Mayors are
working together with civil ngos as well
every citizen of turkey and our friends
from all over the world we're all trying
to stand by the victims of the
earthquake
he says I'm afraid to get uh getting
under jail get undercast it but I want
to say that the government was not
helping us enough we left alone in here
it's true Aid is starting to arrive this
makeshift Refugee Center offers food
water and warm clothing donated by
Turkish residents in the north of the
country it's something but it's not
enough says the former Turkish
ambassador to the UK who's now an
opposition MP
from that one the international Aid they
should not focus on food or any kind of
other issues but the sustainability of
the living conditions there the living
conditions are terrible because there's
no natural gas there's no water no
electricity and the sewage system has
destroyed has been destroyed
as the desperate displays settle
uneasily into another freezing night
below canvas countries including the UK
has sent thermal blankets medical
supplies under 24 7 field Hospital
erdogan has three months until an
election he'll need to rely on
significant support from the
International Community if his 20th
tenure is to continue on after the worst
natural disaster here in living memory
Cape early Sky News in adeyaman